vamos a practicar cómo calcular rangos
inter cuartil es aquí he copiado algunos
ejercicios del portal de khan academy
para resolverlos en el pizarrón
electrónico los siguientes puntos de
datos representan el número de galletas
de animalitos en las loncheras de los
alumnos ordena los datos de menor a
mayor
esos son los datos y nos dicen encuentra
el rango inter cuartil del conjunto de
datos los invito a que traten de
resolver esto por su cuenta antes de que
veamos la solución aquí
vamos a ordenarlo si hiciéramos esto en
la sección de ejercicios de khan academy
podríamos tomar estos números y
cambiarlos de lugar para ordenarlos pero
lo haremos a mano aquí tengo este 4 lo
quito de aquí luego tengo este otro 4
quito este otro
veamos hay algún 5 no pero hay un 6 lo
escribo aquí y lo quito de aquí luego
hay un 7 no parece haber un 8 o un 9
pero si hay un 10 hay un 11
no hay 13 pero si un 14
y finalmente un 15 lo primero que
queremos hacer es encontrar la mediana
aquí
la mediana es el número de enmedio aquí
tengo uno dos tres cuatro cinco seis
siete ocho y nueve números por lo que
tendré un solo número en medio porque
tenemos una cantidad impar de números
nuestra mediana tiene cuatro números a
la derecha y cuatro números a la
izquierda nuestra mediana será el 10
noten que tenemos cuatro a la derecha y
cuatro a la izquierda el rango inter
cuartil trata de encontrar la diferencia
entre la mediana de la primera mitad y
la mediana de la segunda mitad es una
forma de medir qué tan separados están
estos puntos de datos vamos a calcular
la mitad de la primera mitad vamos a
ignorar la mediana y vamos a ver estos
primeros cuatro números y como tengo
cuatro números que es par voy a calcular
la mediana promediando estos dos números
de en medio de cuatro y seis tenemos que
en medio está el 5 o podemos decir que 4
+ 6 dividido entre 2 es igual a 10 entre
2 que nos da 5 la mediana de la primera
mitad de 5 que lo imaginamos aquí y
estemos lo mismo de la segunda mitad nos
fijamos en los dos números de enmedio
que son 12 y 14 el promedio de 12 y 14
va a ser 13 12 más catorce dividido
entre 2 es 26 entre 2 lo que nos da 13
pero la forma de promediar estos números
es ver cuál es el número que está a la
mitad de 12 y 14 ya lo tenemos aquí está
la mediana de la primera mitad que es 5
y tenemos la mediana de la segunda mitad
que es 13 y para calcular el rango inter
cuartil tenemos que calcular la
diferencia entre estas dos cantidades el
rango inter cuartil para este primer
ejemplo va a ser 13 menos 5 la mediana
de la segunda mitad menos la mediana de
la primera mitad que es igual a 8
hagamos más ejercicios que son bastante
interesantes encuentra el rango inter
cuartil de los datos en la siguiente
gráfica de puntos las canciones en cada
álbum de la colección de saint como
siempre los invito a que traten de
resolverlo aquí tenemos los datos
representados de manera diferente pero
podemos ordenar la información vamos a
hacerlo aquí tenemos un álbum con siete
canciones
tenemos un 7 tenemos dos álbumes con
nueve canciones cada uno tenemos dos
nueves tenemos tres con diez
los tachamos y lo escribimos luego
tenemos un 11 tenemos 2 con 12
y finalmente tenemos un álbum con 14
canciones
todo lo que hice fue tomar esta
información y la exprese así hay un
álbum con siete canciones un álbum con
nueve canciones y otro álbum con nueve
canciones etcétera y además la forma en
la que puse los datos también los ordenó
por lo que puedo comenzar a calcular la
mediana directamente tenemos uno dos
tres cuatro cinco seis siete ocho nueve
diez números es una cantidad par por lo
que para calcular la mediana debo de
fijarme en los dos números de enmedio y
estos números son estos dos dieces de
aquí tengo cuatro números a la derecha
de ellos y cuatro a la izquierda
calcular la mediana de dos números es
encontrar el número que está a la mitad
de ambos hay que promediar estos dos
números y el promedio entre 10 y 10 va a
ser 10 la mediana va a ser 10
y en un caso como éste en donde calculé
la mediana usando los dos números de
enmedio pues ahora voy a incluir el de
la izquierda en la primera mitad y el de
la derecha en la segunda mitad la
primera mitad son estos cinco números y
la segunda mitad son estos otros cinco
números
lo que es lógico porque estoy dividiendo
todo mi conjunto justo a la mitad 5 en
un lado y 5 en el otro si tuviéramos un
número justo en el medio como en el
ejemplo anterior lo ignore haríamos al
formar nuestra primera y segunda mitad o
al menos es así como lo estamos haciendo
en estos ejemplos puedes la mediana de
la primera mitad
si tenemos cinco números tenemos una
cantidad impar de números
vamos a tener un solo número a la mitad
y será aquel con dos números a ambos
lados que es este nueve la mediana de la
segunda mitad donde tenemos uno dos tres
cuatro cinco números y el 12 está justo
en el medio con dos números a la derecha
y dos números a la izquierda pues la
mediana de la segunda mitad es este 12
por lo que el rango inter cuartil es la
diferencia de la mediana de la segunda
mitad
12 - la mediana de la primera mitad
a ser igual a 3 si resolveremos esto en
el portal de ejercicios escribiríamos un
3 acá hagamos otro ejercicio todos estos
ejercicios tienen los datos
representados de distinta manera la
siguiente tabla de frecuencias muestra
el número de suspensiones para cada
estudiante en el programa de aprendizaje
alternativo loras aquí está la tabla de
suspensiones y estudiantes encuentra el
rango inter cuartil del conjunto de
datos la clave aquí es escribir todos
los datos ordenados de menor a mayor
tenemos un estudiante con tres
suspensiones
dos estudiantes con cuatro suspensiones
cada uno aquí estoy escribiendo el
número de suspensiones por cada
estudiante tres estudiantes con cinco
suspensiones
un estudiante con seis suspensiones
y un estudiante con siete suspensiones
ya tengo la lista de suspensiones por
cada estudiante y ya está ordenada por
lo que puedo calcular la mediana
inmediatamente tenemos unos dos tres
cuatro cinco seis siete ocho números
para calcular la mediana me enfoco en
los dos números de enmedio que son estos
dos cincos
y el punto medio entre 5 y 55
la mediana aquí es 5
para encontrar el rango inter cuartil
calculamos la mediana de la primera
mitad los primeros cuatro números y la
mediana de la segunda mitad los últimos
cuatro números y nuevamente ya que tengo
dos números en medio el de la izquierda
lo incluyó en la primera mitad y el de
la derecha lo incluyó en la segunda
mitad si tuviera un número justo a la
mitad como en el primer ejemplo lo
ignore haríamos y nos concentraríamos en
la primera y segunda mitad la media de
34 45 es como la cantidad de los números
que tengo aquí es par me voy a
concentrar en los dos números de enmedio
la mitad entre 4 y 4 o el promedio de 4
y 4 va a ser 4 lo escribimos acá y de
este otro lado en la mitad entre 5 y 6
que son nuestros números de enmedio pues
tendremos que el promedio de 5 y 6 es
5.556 es 11 11 entre 2 es 5.5 nuestro
rango inter cuartil es la diferencia
entre la mediana de las
segunda mitad y la mediana de la primera
mitad así que es igual a 5.54 que nos da
1.5
es 1.5 y con esto terminamos